here's a tricky probability question  three numbers are randomly selected with  replacement from the set of integers  from 0 to 9. if the first number  selected is X the second is y and the  third is z what is the probability X is  less than y is less than Z  to work it out we first count the total  number of possibilities there are three  numbers each with 10 options so we have  10 times 10 times 10 which is equal to  10 to the three or one thousand now we  need the three numbers to have X less  than y is less than Z so clearly the  three numbers need to be distinct for  any unordered set of three different  numbers there's exactly one way to  arrange the numbers in ascending order  so let's count the number of unordered  triples of different numbers each of  these will give one success  there are 10 choose three ways to do  this which is equal to 120 so the  probability is 120 divided by 1000 which  equals 0.12 or 3 over 25.